♪ ♪ ♪
- Section 1 au centre!
- Ces aspirants policiers
près de 20 heures en maintien
abababablissement de l'ordre.
Et le contenu a été révinininins
étudiantes de 2012.
PIERRE SAVARD, formation initi.
patrouille et gendarmerie.
- On dit souve é é é é é é é é e
immense en termes de maintien
et rétablissement de l'ordre
au Québec. Il y a eu
énor
(raffut)
atatatatation)
- Ce laboratoire, c'est en faits
au Québec entre févrieret septe.
de 3500 arrestations
et parfois des blessés.sosososo,
c'était un point de ralliement
pour les manifestations de soir.
- Lynda Khelil était
des mani é é é é é étudiantes
en 2012. Aujourd'hui,
elle travaille pour un organisme
de manifester. Selon elle,
s s s s s s pratiques de l'époqe
comme les arrestations de masse
ont nui à ce droit démocrat
LYNDA KHELIL, porte-parole,
Ligues des droits et lib       s
de dissuader beaucoup
de personne et, en même temps,
ça a créé aussi un sentiment
de colère chez beaucoup
- Le travail policier a aussi
été dénoncé par plus
Depuis 10 ans, des tribunaux
et des comités de déontologie
ont donné raisararararararararas
pendant les événements.
- C'est leririririririncipal
qu'on peut tirer de 2012.
C'est que la police a agi à
à la vie et à la sécurité
fefefefefefefestants.
- Si vous pourriez regarder
des images de 2012 et vous
dire : Ça, là, ça, c'était
problé p p p p p p p p p p p p r
ces images-là puis on pourrait
fort probablement dire :
Ça, on fait plus ça comme ça.
travaillait au Service
de la police de Montréal.
Son constat : les patrouilleurs
dépêchés sur les lieux ne sont
contrairement aux escouades
spécialisées.
- Essayez d'être coordonnés!
- Depuis, l'École
nationale de police a su
Ménard publié en 2014
pourorororororororormation
etça commence par
un enseignement théorique.
- Puis, on insiste beaucoup
sur la recons s s s s s s s s sr
la liberté d'expression et
le droit aux gens de s'exprimer.
(La foule scande.)
-
- La deuxième recommandatio
rapport, c'était qu'on insiste,
avec nos aspirants policiers,
de stress et des émotions.
On se rappelle tous
qui énénénénénénénénénénénénéné.
- On est en position?
- Moi, je m'attends
à un policier qui est capable
qui est très discipliné,
qui va travailler en équ
qui va prendre soin de
ses partenaires de chaque côté
puis qu'il partira
avec les manifestants.
- Au pas de
- L'enseignement mise aussi
davantage sur l'arrestation
ciblée c c c c c c c c c c c c s
contrairement aux arrestations
a a a a a a a a a vues en 2012.
- On a émis un paquet
de contraventions.
On a arêté des gens.
Les gens ont contesté.
Donc, les décisionsunununununune
que c'est une pratique qui est .
- La formation sur l'utilisation
des armes d'impact n'est pas
mais plutôt par les services
policiers qui ont des escouades
spécialisée.
- C'est ces deux types-là
qu'on va voir.
à la Sûreté du Québec.
Depuis 2012, comment
les interventions ont évolué
au sein de la SQ?
CLAUDE ST-GERMAIN,
- Je vousu remonterais même
au Sommet de1.1.1.1.1.1.1.1.1.1.
On était en mode on pourrait
dire protection, après ça,
il y a
d'un endroit, Victoriaville,
protection d'un centre de
congrès. Et là, maintenant,
on est plus en encadrement
dès le début des foules.
Vous pouvez voir ici, dans
nos locaux, il faut toujours
être prêt à intervenir.avoir unn
pour participer à ce genre
d'événement-là.
par la SQ ne sont plus les mêmes
qu c c c c c c c c c c ce sont
pour des raisons technologiques
qu'elles ont été remplacées
Toutefois, selon Claudequququque
terrain en 2012 à Victoriaville,
les agents habiletés
aujourd'hui moins nombreux.C'C't
spécialisé qu'on a à la Sûreté
du Québec pour utiliser
les armes intermédiaires
d'impact à projectiles.
- À l'instar de la Sûreté Q Q Qe
de la police de la Ville
Montréal forononononononononono.
Mais notre demande d'entrevue a
été refusée, car des procédu
de 2012 sont toujours en cours.e
les grenades assourdissant
- Leur stratégie aussi c'est
comme de contenir...
- Malgynynynynynynynynynynynynyl
voudrait bien voir les
gouvernements s'impliquer
davantage.e e e e e e e e e e ee
dans quelques années.
Puis on peut le dire parce qu'il
y a pas eu de retrait des armes
Puis, ça, c'est la toute
première chose à faire.
Le problème, c'est qu'on peut
formation, mais la formation,ea.
Donc, ça agit sur le policie
pas individuel,titititititititi.
où on est rendus par rapport
à où on ét
- Pierre Savard est quant à lui
optimiste. Il est persuadé
ouououououououououououououououor
les aspirants policiers.
- La journée même où vous allez
vivre une manifestation qui este
contents de l'avoi
y a un paquet de policiers
qui étaient sur le terrain
le niveau de formation
qu'i